tard monsieur jean-sébastien vialatte
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
affaires sociales et de la santé
elle concerne le décret paru au journal
officiel le 25 mars modifiant la prise
en charge des traitements innovants
onéreux dans la liste dite en sus ce
mécanisme selon lequel le coût est
déplacée du budget de l'hôpital vers
celui de l'assurance maladie ce qui
permet d'en assurer l'accès à tous les
patients dispensés à l'hôpital ces
traitements innovants été remboursés à
100% par l'assurance maladie
ils ne le seront plus le professeur
philippe de l'instit directeur de
l'institut curie avait attiré votre
attention sur le peu de pertinence sur
un plan éthique de faire de cette liste
une priorité de régulation budgétaire
qui risque de le contraindre à renoncer
à ces traitements innovants pourtant
indispensables pour améliorer la vie de
patients atteints de cancer avec pour
certains l'obligation de refuser leur
participation aux essais cliniques
faute de pouvoir financer des
traitements comparateur ce décret remet
en cause le principe d'égalité d'accès
aux soins
désormais seuls ceux qui pourront
répondre financièrement pourront en
bénéficier
de plus il manque de cohérence avec le
troisième plan cancer
l'inquiétude avait pris de l'ampleur le
14 mars une liste de 110 personnalités
réunies
réunissant les plus grands noms de la
scène cancérologie dénoncé dans la
presse l'explosion des prix de ces
médicaments tout en proposant des
solutions concrètes pour leur maintien
en milieu hospitalier
aussi madame la ministre pouvez vous
nous dire quelles sont les initiatives à
l'échelle nationale que vous envisagez
pour remédier aux besoins urgents des
patients qui nécessitent des traitements
désormais remis en question dans notre
pays
madame la ministre serez-vous celle qui
refusera de très nombreuses femmes
l'accès aux médicaments innovants
traitant le cancer du sein
la parole est à madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales et de la
santé
oui
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sur les députés monsieur le député
vialatte
il ne s'agit en aucun cas de
dérembourser la france est un pays dans
lequel les traitements même très coûteux
sont accordées à tous les malades qui en
ont besoin et c'est la politique que je
suis et c'est la politique qui sera
poursuivie la liste ont su c'est quoi la
liste en sus c'est quoi ça veut dire que
certains traitements très innovant ne
peuvent pas être financés sur le budget
classique globale de l'hôpital mais
doivent être financées en plus et c'est
cela que nous devons préserver pour cela
un décret a été pris qui définit les
critères pour être financées sur cette
liste si l'on n'est pas sur cette liste
qui pour le moment n'a pas été publié on
est financé par le budget global de
l'hôpital et donc je ne vous laisserai
pas dire monsieur le député je ne vous
laisserai pas dire à vous qui avait
procédé à des déremboursements de
médicaments lorsque vous étiez de
responsabilités que ce gouvernement ne
soignera pas toutes les sommes et tous
les femmes qui en ont besoin
cette liste elle définit des critères
sécuritaires c'est quoi que le
médicament soit très innovant ou
innovant qu'il soit coûteux c'est à dire
que l'hôpital ne puisse pas le payer sur
son budget normal et que par ailleurs
ils représentent évidemment une avancée
importante si le médicament n'est pas
innovant il peut malgré tout être
financés par cette liste dès lors qu'ils
représentent un intérêt de santé
publique
tout est fait monsieur le député pour
que les françaises et les français qui
ont besoin de traitements puissent y
accéder et être soigné c'est ce que nous
avons fait pour l'essai c'est ce que
nous faisons pour les cancers c'est ce
que nous faisons pour tous les
médicaments
l'innovation c'est une ligne de force
l'innovation c'est pour moi une priorité
et c'est le sens de la politique de ce
gouvernement
merci madame la ministre la séance de
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue